john you're up well hello there reject
nation welcome
to another trailer reaction featuring
your boys john and greg
we're gonna be checking out the willy's
wonderland trailer not the history of
swearing on netflix which you should all
go check out it's really funny i was
watching a couple episodes this week
don't know much about this movie
other than it looks like a freaky ass
version of five nights at freddy's
let's do this very good john thanks greg
[Music]
oh he's gonna drive angry
a chicken soup for the soul
entertainment
i am officially sold
this is my most anticipated movie
a word i've been already he's gonna die
in here but he won't listen to me
oh he wants it
[Music]
oh it is straight up five nights at
freddy's
that house is gonna be pissed
i love this do not mess with the cage
put your balls on
oh yes
[Music]
dude this looks awesome
oh my god comes at him on olivia's
birthday
that is exactly the kind of movie she
would want i didn't know what to get you
for your birthday
olivia i think i finally figured it out
you're going to be very disappointed in
my selection
because i don't think you would care to
watch this as much as i would video on
demand
watching willy's wonderland that looks
so
cool i love that it looks so self-aware
i had heard that's a nick cage movie
violent kind of five nights at freddy's
that's what i that's
literally everything i heard so when i
was watching this i was like oh this
looks exactly like five nights at the
animatronics dude to me
yeah you mentioned blumhouse they are
working on a five nights at freddy's
movie so they say yeah they've been for
a little while with the creator
i don't think there is any chance in
hell it can live up
to this this is the five nights at
freddy's movie
right here this is how you do it i mean
to get nicholas cage in there like what
other personality because think about it
like this
if this was just called five nights at
freddy's anytime you do a video game
adaptation you're like oh crap who's
gonna play the main character
like you can already see what the
blumhouse trailer is it's super serious
super dramatic yeah yeah yeah this chick
down in her luck she takes a job at a
you know this
run down child you know entertainment
places
obviously jump scare relatable yeah
she's got a little brother who she looks
out all by herself i mean
don't get me wrong there are some pretty
amazing blumhouse movies out there
but you know what kind of comes to mind
but the second you say nick cage is
gonna be in it and the way they're
directing it
just with its crazy camera angles it's
kinetic energy
it's wild like grungy dirty filthy
cinematography
pure grindhouse and then nicholas cage
looks like he's such a stoic type of
character who then starts
becoming unleashed and becoming full-on
nick cage as he
indulges in the violence of it all this
just seems like a total blast like to me
this is how you make your five nights at
freddy's movie
stand out you know that is exactly what
i what i was thinking is yeah
instead of going that traditional route
of like no no we gotta endear you to
like a flashlight
yeah yeah we're doing the pov like it's
not gonna
be pov but there's gonna be a tribute
sequence that's like four minutes of pov
someone in the security camera you just
know like the crap it would be and this
is
this is like this would be the
adaptation to make right here yeah yeah
yeah
bob zombie five nights at freddy's yes
exactly it's like you bypass that
entirely by going
who's a personality that would be crazy
to just throw
into this anyway yeah nicholas cage i
mean
i do appreciate that trope in these
kinds of movies of like
the drifter who's probably got a crazy
past or something who's really quiet who
gets some kind of small town thing and
then uses it somehow as like a means of
unleashing all this pent-up trauma and
rage
yeah that like motivates him to be that
silent badass to begin with i mean
obviously this this is like a hard r
movie but it's funny too because it
almost looks nastier the way he's
beating these animatronics they're like
spraying
oil on it and stuff and so it's like
what's oil what's blood it all looks
nasty and yeah it's self-aware but at
least as of this trailer what it's
suggesting to me is
not too self-aware to the point that
they're not actually trying to do
anything punchy or or
nifty with it i feel like sometimes you
can get lazy and
rest on self-awareness and kind of take
some of the intensity out but this looks
like it will still maintain
some kind of edge and even though
they're not a big part of this trailer
and even though nick cage is like the
thing
that you know is gravitating everyone
towards it i am curious to see how he
like interfaces with the rest of the
staff because i can also see this being
one of those movies that has
a surprisingly fun and colorful
supporting cast as well
because like the woman who's uh like the
you know sheriff lady or whatever like
she's a great character actually oh no
this movie
this movie has a great trailer but it's
gonna for sure one of his subgenres has
to be a comedy
yeah i highly doubt if i like the third
on the list
yeah where the characters have such a
personality about them i mean
yeah like he's a drifter at first but
he's also like looks like an
action hero yeah you see him on screen
drifter with the pitching car and the
sunglasses the shades he just looks like
he's ready to throw down
yeah the second you see him that
immediately told me okay this is
this is a little different so i didn't
know anything about what the uh
tonal or imagery approach was gonna be
like with this so
see what they're doing with it yeah i
mean i'm very much excited i think this
is this is the way to go man and uh this
is gonna be
funny it's gonna be intense it's gonna
be
violent hell yeah i don't know nicholas
cage every once in a while makes a good
film
he got it well that's the thing every
every once in a while it makes a good
one he looks like a good one
he's the br he's the broken clock that's
right like three or four times
he really when people find the right
pitch for him can really
elevate and bring things to life in a
way no other actor does
and i think he has a lot of fun with
these there's some there's a nick cage
where you know he's just getting his
paycheck
and then there's the nick cage where you
know he's he can make something really
fun and cool out of this and i think
this is the latter yeah i'd be very
surprised if i'm wrong
guys what'd you think of the willy's
wonderland trailer i know we're like
five days late to this
super requested from the comments so i
was like you know we should probably
just do it subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
all right john let's do niraj niraj this
is a cameo from nicholas cage i just
want to let you know
you're my favorite indian fan living in
the united states i've met a lot of them
and you are by far
the best and when i'm in the east coast
next we're going to meet up and we're
going to have a good time together we're
going to go get our beards groomed
we're going to go try on some wigs then
you and i we're going to make a couple
home movies together and it's going to
be really fun really awesome and then
we're going to end the night by spooning
on the top of the empire state building
under the moonlight
full nude but covered in like animal
skins and things like that
drinking mojitos till dawn and then
next morning i'm going to pretend like i
don't know you and i'm going to fly back
to los
angeles and keep paying my debts off
very very well look at that that was
good
overstated welcome a little bit like
like a nicholas cage movie yeah
so that's perfect
[Music]